Christmas morning also brought misery to
about 250 people in Minnesota's largest
city they are without a home after a
fire swept through the Drake Hotel in
Minneapolis yesterday the 93 year old
hotel was used to shelter homeless
people no one was seriously hurt but
many of the victims are forced to start
all over again Christian Cordero from
our Minneapolis station WCCO is outside
the hotel and Christian what do we know
about what caused the fire
well Vlad investigators are still
looking into what caused the fire it
will be a while before they can go in
and actually investigate you can see a
couple of fire engines are still out
here the fire itself continued to
smolder and pop throughout the night I
can tell you this morning the smell of
the smoke is still lingering now 24
hours later and the hundreds of people
who were displaced
they also saw they lost everything but
they also saw the power of Minnesota and
the spirit of Christmas we have to smell
the smoke you have to hand people
screaming and looked out it was just
filled with smoke around 3:00 Christmas
morning residents of Minneapolis Drake
Hotel were forced to evacuate after it
went up in flames the four-alarm fire
began on the second floor of the
three-story building and quickly spread
to the Attic the only word that comes to
mind right now is heartbreaking while
fire crews work to put out the fire
residents kept warm on city buses city
leaders say about 250 people many of
them who were already homeless lost all
of their belongings we literally just
started over again and then lost
everything all over what's next I don't
know but I know it could only do greater
while firefighters were on the scene a
Hennepin County official put out the
call for help urging people to donate
supplies to the people affected word
spread quickly on social media and soon
generous Minnesotans showed up with
diapers blankets clothes and shoes
people gave so much that some have to be
turned away I decided that we should go
take some of our Christmas gifts and
donate them to the kids or people that
lost things and the fires Minneapolis is
awesome
sorry it's kind of emotional the
Minnesota Red Cross managed to find the
residents temporary shelter at a church
for the next few evenings but the city
is trying to secure a more long-term
solution these are real people that need
a roof over their heads and they need
help
three people were taken to the hospital
all are expected to recover several
others were treated at the scene here
for smoke inhalation and Dana if anybody
feels implore to donate money to those
in need
the Minnesota Red Cross has set up a
fund well personal Christie on your
heart certainly goes out to all of them
thank you very much
you